you've announced the integration of chat
GPT and Wolfram Alpha and Wolfram
language so let's talk about that
integration what are the key differences
from the high philosophical level
maybe the technical level between the
capabilities of
broadly speaking the two kinds of
systems large language models and this
computational gigantic computational
system infrastructure that is well from
alpha yeah so what does something like
chat GPT do it's it's mostly focused on
make language like the language that
humans have made and put on the web and
so on yeah so you know it's it's primary
sort of underlying technical thing is
you've given a prompt it's trying to
continue that prompt in a way that
somehow typical of what it's seen based
on a trillion words of text that humans
have written on the web and the way it's
doing that is with something which is
probably quite similar to the way we
humans do the first stages of that using
a neural net and so on and just saying
given these given this piece of text
let's Ripple through the neural net one
word and get one word at a time of
output and uh it's kind of a shallow
computation on a large amount of kind of
training data that is what we humans
have put on the web that's a different
thing from sort of the computational
stack that I spent the last I don't know
40 years or so building which has to do
with what can you compute many steps
potentially a very deep computation it's
not sort of taking the statistics of
what we humans have produced and trying
to continue Things based on that
statistics instead it's trying to take
kind of the formal structure that we've
created in our civilization whether it's
from mathematics or whether it's from
kind of systematic knowledge of all
kinds and use that to do arbitrarily
deep computations to figure out things
that that aren't just let's match what's
already been kind of said on the web but
let's potentially be able to compute
something new and different that's never
been computed before so as a practical
matter you know the the um what we're
you know the our goal is to have made as
much as possible of the world computable
in the sense that if there's a question
that in principle is answerable from
some sort of expert knowledge that's
been accumulated we can compute the
answer to that question and we can do it
in a sort of reliable way that's that's
the best one can do given what the
expertise that our civilization has
accumulated it's a very it's a it's a
much more sort of labor-intensive on the
side of kind of being creating kind of
the the computational system to do that
um obviously the in the the kind of the
chat GPT world it's like take things
which were produced for quite other
purposes namely the all the things we've
written out on the web and so on and
sort of forage from that things which
were are like what's been written on the
web so I think you know as a practical
point of view I I view sort of the chat
GPT thing as being wide and shallow and
what we're trying to do with sort of
building out computation as being this
sort of deep also broad but but uh most
importantly kind of uh deep type of
thing I think another way to think about
this is if you go back in human history
you know I don't know a thousand years
or something and you say what what can
the typical person what's the typical
person going to figure out well the
answer is there's certain kinds of
things that we humans can quickly figure
out that's sort of what what our uh you
know other neural architecture and the
kinds of things we learn in our lives
let us do but then there's this whole
layer of kind of formalization that got
developed in which is you know the kind
of whole sort of story of intellectual
history and the whole kind of depth of
learning that formalization turned into
things like logic mathematics science
and so on and that's the kind of thing
that allows one to kind of build these
towers of of uh uh of of uh sort of
towers of things you work out it's not
just I can immediately figure this out
it's no I can use this kind of formalism
to go step by step and work out
something which was not immediately
obvious to me and that's kind of the
story of what what we're trying to do
computational is to be able to build
those kind of tall towers of what
implies what implies what and so on
um and uh as opposed to kind of the yes
I can immediately figure it out it's
just like what I saw somewhere else in
something that I heard or remembered or
something like this what can you say
about the kind of formal structure the
kind of form of foundation you can build
such a formal structure on about the
kinds of things you would start on in
order to build this kind of uh deep
computable knowledge trees so the
question is sort of how do you how do
you think about computation and there's
there's a couple of points here one is
what computation intrinsically is like
and the other is what aspects of
computation we humans with our minds and
with the kinds of things we've learned
can sort of relate to in that
computational universe so if we start on
the kind of what can computation be like
it's something I've spent some big chunk
of my life studying is imagine that
you're you know we usually write
programs where we kind of know what we
want the program to do and we carefully
write in many lines of code and we hope
that the program does what we what we
intended it to do but the thing I've
been interested in is if you just look
at the kind of natural science of
programs so you just say I'm going to
make this program it's a really tiny
program maybe I even pick the pieces of
the program at random but it's really
tiny by really tiny I mean you know less
than a line of code type thing you say
what does this program do and you run it
and big discovery that I made in the
early 80s is that even extremely simple
programs when you run them can do really
complicated things really surprised me
it took me several years to kind of
realize that that was a thing so to
speak but that that realization that
even very simple programs can do
incredibly complicated things that we
very much don't expect
that Discovery I mean I realized that
that's very much I think how nature
works that is nature has simple rules
but yet does all sorts of complicated
things that we might not expect you know
as a big thing of the last few years has
been understanding that that's how the
whole universe and physics works but
that's a a quite separate topic but so
there's this whole world of programs and
what they do and very rich sophisticated
things that these programs can do but
when we look at many of these programs
we look at them and say well that's kind
of I don't really know what that's doing
it's not a very human kind of thing
so on the one hand we have sort of
what's possible in the computational
universe on the other hand we have the
kinds of things that we humans think
about the kinds of things that are
developed in kind of our intellectual
history and that's uh and the Really the
challenge to sort of making things
computational is to connect what's
computationally possible out in the
computational universe with the things
that we humans sort of typically think
about with our minds now that's a
complicated kind of moving Target
because the things that we think about
change over time we've learned more
stuff we've invented mathematics we've
invented various kinds of ideas and
structures and so on so it's gradually
expanding we're kind of gradually
colonizing more and more of this kind of
intellectual space of possibilities but
the the real thing the real challenge is
how do you take what is computationally
possible how do you take how do you
encapsulate the kinds of things that we
think about in a way that kind of plugs
into what's computationally possible and
and actually the the uh the big sort of
idea there is this idea of kind of
symbolic programming symbolic
representations of things and so the the
question is when you look at sort of
everything in the world and you kind of
you know you take some visual scene or
something you're looking at and you say
well how do I turn that into something
that I can kind of stuff into my mind
you know there are lots of pixels in my
visual scene but the things that I
remembered from that visual scene are
you know there's a there's a chair in
this place it's a kind of a symbolic
representation of the visual scene there
are two chairs on a table or something
rather than there are all these pixels
arranged in all these detailed ways and
so the question then is how do you take
sort of all the all the things in the
world and make some kind of
representation that corresponds to the
types of ways that we think about things
and human language is is sort of one
form of representation that we have we
talk about chairs that's a word in human
language and so on how do we how do we
take but human language is is not in and
of itself something from that plugs in
very well to sort of computation it's
not something from which you can
immediately compute consequences and so
on and so you have to kind of find a way
to take sort of the the stuff we
understand from human language and make
it more precise and that's really this
story of of symbolic programming and you
know what what that turns into is
something which I didn't know at the
time it was going to work as well as it
has but back in the 1979 or so I was
trying to build my first big computer
system and trying to figure out you know
how should I represent computations at a
high level and I kind of invented this
idea of using kind of symbolic
Expressions you know structured as it's
kind of like a a function and a bunch of
arguments but that function doesn't
necessarily evaluate to anything it's
just a a thing that sits there
representing a structure and so building
up that structure and it's turned out
that structure has been extremely it's
it's a good match for the way that we
humans it seems to be a good match for
the way that we humans kind of
conceptualize higher level things and
it's been the last I don't know 45 years
or something it's served me remarkably
well so building up that structure using
this kind of symbolic representation but
what can you say about abstractions here
because you could just start with your
physics project you could start at a
hypograph at a very very low level and
build up everything from there but you
don't you type shortcuts right uh you
take the highest level of abstraction
convert that
uh the kind of abstraction that's
convertible to something computable
using symbolic representation
and then that's your new foundation for
that little piece of knowledge yeah
somehow all of that is integrated right
so the the sort of a very important
phenomenon that that is kind of a thing
that I've sort of realized is just it's
one of these things that sort of in the
in the future of kind of everything is
going to become more and more important
is this phenomenon of computational
irreducibility and the the question is
if you know the rules for something you
have a program you're going to run it
you might say I know the rules great I
know everything about what's going to
happen well in principle you do because
you can just run those rules out and
just see what they do you might run them
a million steps you see what happens Etc
the question is can you like immediately
jump ahead and say I know it's going to
happen after a million steps and the
answer is 13 or something yes and the
the one of the very critical things to
realize is if you could reduce that
computation there isn't a sense no point
in doing the computation the place where
you really get value out of doing
computation is when you had to do the
computation to find out the answer but
this phenomenon that you have to do the
computation to find out the answer this
phenomenon of computational
irreducibility seems to be tremendously
important for thinking about lots of
kinds of things so one of the things
that happens is okay you've got a model
of the universe at the low level in
terms of atoms of space and hypographs
and rewriting typographs and so on and
it's happening you know 10 to the 100
times every second let's say well you
say great then we've we've nailed it
we've we know how the universe works
well the problem is the universe can
figure out what it's going to do it does
those 10 to the 100 you know steps but
for us to work out what it's going to do
we have no way to reduce that
computation the only way to do the
computation to see the result of the
computation is to do it and if we're
operating within the universe we're kind
of there's no there's no opportunity to
do that because the universe is doing it
as fast as the universe can do it and
that's you know that's what's happening
so what we're trying to do and a lot of
the story of science a lot of other
kinds of things is finding pockets of
reducibility that is you could have a
situation where everything in the world
is full of computational irreducibility
we never know what's going to happen
next the only way we can figure out
what's going to happen next is just let
the system run and see what happens so
in a sense the story of of most kinds of
science inventions a lot of kinds of
things is the story of finding these
places where we can locally jump ahead
and one of the features of computational
reducibility is that there are always
pockets of reducibility there are always
places there always an infinite number
of places where you can jump ahead
there's no way where you can jump
completely ahead but there are little
little patches little places where you
can jump ahead a bit and I think you
know we can talk about physics project
and so on but I think the thing we
realize is we kind of exist in a slice
of all the possible computational
irreducibility in the universe we exist
in a slice where there's a reasonable
amount of predictability and in a sense
as we try and construct these kind of
higher levels of of abstraction symbolic
representations and so on what we're
doing is we're finding these lumps of
reducibility that we can kind of attach
ourselves to and about which we can kind
of have fairly simple narrative things
to say because in principle you know I
say what's going to happen in the next
few seconds you know oh there are these
molecules moving around in the air in
this room and oh gosh it's an incredibly
complicated story
um and that's a whole computational
irresistible thing most of which I don't
care about and most of it is well you
know the air is still going to be here
and nothing much is going to be
different about it and that's a kind of
reducible fact about what is ultimately
a an underlying level of computational
irreducible process
and uh life would not be possible if we
didn't have a large number of such
reducible Pockets uh yes Pockets
amenable to uh reduction into something
symbolic yes I think so I mean life in
in the way that we experience it that I
mean you know one might you know
depending on what we mean by life so to
speak the the the experience that we
have of sort of consistent things
happening in the world the idea of space
for example where there's you know we
can just say you're here you move there
it's kind of the same thing it's still
you in that different place even though
you're made of different atoms of space
and so on this is this idea that it's uh
that there's sort of this level of
predictability of what's going on that's
us finding a slice of reducibility in
what is underneath this computationally
reducible kind of system and I think
that's that's sort of the thing which is
actually my favorite discovery of the
last few years is the realization that
it is sort of the interaction between
this sort of underlying computational
irreducibility and our nature as kind of
observers who sort of have to key into
computational reducibility that fact
leads to the main laws of physics that
we discovered in throughout his century
so this is we talked about this in in
more detail but this is a uh to me it's
kind of our nature as observers the fact
that we are computationally bounded
observers we don't get to follow all
those little pieces of computational
irreducibility to stuff what is about
out there in the world into our minds
requires that we are looking at things
that are reducible we are compressing
kind of we're extracting just some
Essence some kind of symbolic essence of
what's the detail of what's going on in
the world that together with one other
condition that at first seems sort of
trivial but isn't which is that we
believe we are persistent in time
causality here's the thing at every
moment according to our Theory we're
made of different atoms of space
at every moment sort of the microscopic
detail of what what the universe is made
of is being Rewritten and that's and in
fact the very fact that there's
coherence between different parts of
space is a consequence of the fact that
there are all these little processes
going on that kind of knit together the
structure of space it's kind of like if
you wanted to have a fluid with a bunch
of molecules in it if those molecules
weren't interacting you wouldn't have
this fluid that would pour and do all
these kinds of things it would just be
sort of a free-floating collection of
molecules so similarly it is with space
that the fact that space is kind of
knitted together as a consequence of all
this activity in space and the fact that
kind of what we consist of sort of this
this series of of uh you know we're
continually being Rewritten and the
question is why is it the case that we
think of ourselves as being the same us
through time that's kind of a key
assumption I think it's a key aspect of
what we see as sort of our Consciousness
so to speak is that we have this kind of
consistent thread of experience well
isn't that just another
limitation
of our mind that we want to reduce
reality into some that kind of temporal
yeah consistency is just a nice
narrative right tell ourselves well the
fact is I think it's critical to the way
we humans typically operate is that we
have a single thread of experience you
know if you if you imagine sort of a
mind where you have you know maybe
that's what's happening in various kinds
of Minds that aren't working the same
way other minds work is that you're
splitting into multiple threads of
experience it's also it's also something
where you know when you look at I don't
know Quantum Mechanics for example in
the insides of quantum mechanics it's
splitting into many threads of
experience but in order for us humans to
interact with it you kind of have to
have to knit all those different threads
together so that we say oh yeah a
definite thing happened and now the next
definite thing happens and so on and I
think you know sort of inside uh it's
it's sort of interesting to try and
imagine what's it like to have kind of
these uh fundamentally multiple threads
of experience going on I mean right now
different human Minds have different
threads of experience we just have a
bunch of Minds that are interacting with
each other but we don't have a you know
within each mind there's a single thread
and that's a that is indeed a
simplification I think it's a it's a
thing you know the general computational
system does not have that simplification
and um it's one of the things you know I
I people often seem to think that you
know Consciousness is the highest level
of kind of things that can happen in the
universe so to speak but I think that's
not true I think it's actually a a
specialization in which among other
things you have this idea of a single
thread of experience which is not a
general feature of anything that could
kind of computationally happen in the
universe so it's the feature of a
computationally limited system that's
only able to
observe
reducible Pockets so yeah so I mean this
word Observer it means something in
quantum mechanics it means something
in a lot of places it means something to
us humans right as conscious beings so
what what's the importance of the
Observer what is the Observer and what's
the importance of the observer in the
computational universe so this question
of what is an observer what's the
general idea of an observer it's
actually one of my next projects which
got somewhat derailed by the the current
sort of AI Mania but um is there a
connection there or is that uh do you do
you think the Observer is primarily a
physics phenomena is it related to the
whole AI thing yes yes it is related so
one question is what is a general
Observer so you know we know we have an
idea what is a general computational
system we think about Turing machines we
think about other models of computation
there's a question what is a general
model of an observer and the there's
kind of observers like us which is kind
of The Observers we're interested in you
know we could imagine an alien Observer
that deals with computational
irreducibility and it has a mind that's
utterly different from ours and and
completely incoherent with what what
we're like but the fact is that that you
know if we are talking about observers
like us that one of the key things is
this idea of kind of taking all the
detail of the world and being able to
stuff it into a mind being able to take
all the detail and kind of you know
extract out of it a smaller set of of
kind of degrees of freedom a smaller
number of elements that will sort of fit
in our minds and I think this this
question so I've been interested in
trying to characterize what is the
general Observer and the general
Observer is I think in part there are
many let me give an example of a you
know you have a gas it's got a bunch of
molecules bouncing around and the thing
you're measuring about the gas is its
pressure and the only I think you as an
observer care about is pressure and that
means you have a piston on the side of
this box and the Piston is being pushed
by the gas and there are many many
different ways that molecules can hit
that piston but all that matters is the
kind of aggregate of all those molecular
impacts because that's what determines
pressure so there's a huge number of
different configurations of the gas
which are all equivalent so I think one
key aspect of observers is this
equivalency of many different
configurations of a system saying all I
care about is this aggregate feature all
I care about is this this overall thing
and that's that's sort of one one aspect
and when we see that in lots of
different again it's the same story over
and over again that there's there's a
lot of detail in the world but what we
are extracting from it is something a
sort of a thin uh a thin summary of that
of that detail is that thin summary
nevertheless true is can it be a crappy
approximation sure that on average is is
correct I mean if we look at the observe
that's the human mind it seems like
there's a lot of very
um as represented by natural language
for example there's a lot of really
crappy approximation sure and that could
be maybe a feature of it well with this
ambiguity right right you don't know you
know it could be the case you're just
measuring the aggregate impacts of these
molecules but there is some tiny tiny
probability that molecules will arrange
themselves in some really funky way and
that just measuring that average isn't
going to the main point yeah by the way
an awful lot of science is very confused
about this because you know you look at
you look at papers and people are really
Keen they draw this curve and they have
these you know these bars on the curve
and things it's just this curve and it's
this one thing and it's supposed to
represent some system that has all kinds
of details in it and this is a way that
lots of science has gotten wrong because
people say I remember years ago I was
studying snowflake growth you know you
have a snowflake and it's growing it has
all these arms it's doing complicated
things but there was a literature on
this stuff and it talked about you know
what's the rate of snowflake growth and
you know it got pretty good answers for
the rate of the growth of the Snowflake
and they looked at it more carefully and
they had these nice curves of you know
snowflake growth rates and so on I
looked at it more carefully and I
realized according to their models the
snowflake will be spherical
and so they got the growth rate right
but the detail was just utterly wrong
and you know that not only the detail
that the whole thing was was not
capturing you know it was capturing this
aspect of the system that was in a sense
missing the main point of what was going
on and what is the geometric uh shape of
a snowflake snowflakes start in in the
phase of water that's relevant to the
formation of snowflakes it's a phase of
ice which starts with a hexagonal
arrangement of water molecules and so it
starts off growing as a hexagonal plate
and then what happens is is the plate oh
oh versus sphere sphere well no no but
it's it's much more than that I mean
snowflakes are fluffy you know typical
snowflakes have little little dendritic
arms yeah and what actually happens is
it's kind of kind of cool because you
can make these very simple discrete
models with cellular automata and things
that that figure this out you start off
with this you know hexagonal thing and
then the places it starts to grow little
arms and every time a little piece of
ice it adds itself to the snowflake the
fact that that ice condensed from the
water vapor heats the snowflake up
locally and so it makes it less likely
for uh for another piece of ice to
accumulate right nearby so this leads to
a kind of growth inhibition you grow an
arm and it is a separated arm because
right around the arm it got a little bit
hot and it didn't add more ice there so
what happens is it grows you have a
hexagon it grows out arms the arms go
arms and then the arms go arms go arms
and eventually actually it's kind of
cool because it actually fills in
another hexagon a bigger hexagon and
when I first looked at this we had a
very simple model for this I realized
you know when it fills in that hexagon
it actually leaves some holes behind so
I thought well you know that is that
really right so look at these pictures
of snowflakes and sure enough they have
these little holes in them that are kind
of scars of the way that these arms grow
out
um so you can't fill in
backfill holes yeah they don't backfill
and presumably there's a limitation of
how big like you can't arbitrarily grow
I'm not sure I mean the thing falls
through the the I mean I think it just
you know it hits the ground at some
point I think you can grow I think you
can grow in the lab I think you can grow
pretty big ones I think you can grow
many many iterations of this kind of
goes from hexagon it grows out arms it
turns back it fills back into a hexagon
it grows more arms again in 3D no it's
flat usually why is it flat why doesn't
it uh span out okay okay wait a minute
you said it's fluffy and fluffy is a
three-dimensional property no or no it's
it's fluffy snow is okay so you know
what makes we're really uh we're really
in it but there's multiple snowflakes
become fluffy a single snowflake is not
fluffy no no single snowflake is Fluffy
and what happens is you know if if you
have snow that it's just pure hexagons
they they can you know they they fit
together pretty well it's not it doesn't
it doesn't make it doesn't have a lot of
air in it and they can also slide
against each other pretty easily and so
the snow can be pretty you know can I
think Adam launches happen sometimes
when when the things tend to be these
you know hexagonal plates and it kind of
slides but then when the thing has all
these arms that have grown out it's not
they don't fit together very well and
that's why the snow has lots of air in
it and if you look at one of these
snowflakes and if you catch one you'll
see it has these little arms and people
actually people often say you know no
two snowflakes are alike
um that's mostly because as a snowflake
grows they do grow pretty consistently
with these different arms and so on but
you capture them at different times as
they you know they fell through through
the air in a different way you'll catch
this one at this stage and as it goes
through different stages they look
really different and so that's why you
know kind of looks like no two slime
flakes are alike because you caught them
at different at different times so the
rules under which they grow are the same
it's just the timing is yes okay so the
point is science is not able to uh
describe the full complexity of
snowflake growth well science if you if
you do what people might often do just
say okay let's make it scientific let's
turn into one number and that one number
is kind of the growth rate of the arms
or some such other thing that fails to
capture sort of the detail of what's
going on inside the system and that's in
a sense a big challenge for science is
how do you extract from the natural
world for example those aspects of it
that you are interested in talking about
now you might just say I don't really
care about the fluffiness of the
snowflakes all I care about is the
growth rate of the arms in which case
you know you have you can have a good
model without knowing anything about the
fluffiness
um but the fact is as a practical you
know when if you if you say what's the
what is the most obvious feature of a
snowflake oh that it has this
complicated shape well then you've got a
different story about what you model I
mean this is one of the features of sort
of modeling and science that you know
what is a Model A model is some way of
reducing the actuality of the world to
something where you can readily sort of
give a narrative for what's happening
where you can basically make some kind
of abstraction of what's happening and
answer questions that you care about
answering if you wanted to answer all
possible questions about the system
you'd have to have the whole system
because you might care about this
particular molecule where did it go and
you know your model which is some big
abstraction of that has nothing to say
about that so you know one of the things
that's that's often confusing in science
is people will have I've got a model
somebody says somebody else will say I
don't believe in your model because it
doesn't capture the feature of the
system that I care about you know
there's always this controversy about
you know is the is it a correct model
well no model is a except for the actual
system itself is a correct model in the
sense that it captures everything
questions does It capture what you care
about capturing sometimes that's
ultimately defined by what you're going
to build technology out of things like
this the one counter example to this is
if you think you're modeling the whole
universe all the way down then there is
a notion of a correct model but even
that is more complicated because it
depends on kind of how observers sample
things and so on that's a that's a
separate story but at least at the first
level to say you know this thing about
oh it's an approximation you're
capturing one aspect you're not
capturing other aspects when you really
think you have a complete model for the
whole universe you better be capturing
ultimately everything even though to
actually run that model is impossible
because of computational reducibility
the only the only thing that
successfully runs that model is the
actual running of the universe is the
universe itself but okay so what you
care about
is an interesting concept so that's a
that's a human concept so that's what
you're doing with uh wolf from Alpha and
Wolfram language is you trying to come
up with symbolic representations yes as
simple as possible
uh so a model that's as simple as
possible that fully captures stuff we
care about yes so I mean for example you
know we could we'll have a a thing about
you know data about movies let's say we
could be describing every individual
pixel in every movie and so on but
that's not the level that people care
about and it's yes this is a I mean and
and that level that people care about is
somewhat related to what's described in
natural language but what what we're
trying to do is to find a way to sort of
represent precisely so you can compute
things see see one thing when you say
you give a piece of natural language
question is you feed it to a computer
you say does the computer understand
this natural language
well you know the computer crosses it in
some way it does this maybe it can make
a continuation of the natural language
you know maybe it can go on from The
Prompt and say what it's going to say
you say does it really understand it
hard to know but for in this kind of
computational world there is a very
definite definition of does it
understand which is could it be turned
into this symbolic computational thing
from which you can compute all kinds of
consequences and that's the that's the
sense in which one has sort of a target
for the understanding of natural
language and that's kind of our goal is
to have as much as possible about the
world that can be computed in a in a
reasonable way so to speak be able to be
sort of captured by this kind of
computational language that's that's
kind of the goal and and I think for us
humans the the main thing that's
important is as we formalize what we're
talking about it gives us a way of kind
of building a structure where we can
sort of build this Tower of consequences
of things so if we're just saying well
let's talk about it in natural language
it doesn't really give us some hard
Foundation that lets us you know build
step by step to work something out and
it's kind of like what happens in math
if we were just sort of vaguely talking
about math but didn't have the kind of
full structure of math and all that kind
of thing we wouldn't be able to build
this kind of big tower of consequences
and so you know in a sense what we're
trying to do with the whole
computational language effort is to make
a formalism for describing the world
that makes it possible to kind of build
this this Tower of consequences well can
you talk about this dance between
natural language and Wolfram language
so there's this gigantic thing called
the internet where people post memes and
diary type thoughts and very important
sounding articles and all that that
makes up the training data set for GPT
and then there's uh Wolfram language
how can you map from the natural
language of the internet to the Wolfram
language is there an
manual is there an automated way of
doing that as we look into the future
well so Wolfram Alpha what it does it's
kind of front end is turning natural
language into computational language
right what you mean by that is there's a
prompt you ask a question what is the
capital of yeah and it turns into you
know what's the distance between you
know Chicago and London or something and
that will turn into you know
geo-distance of entity City you know Etc
et cetera et cetera each one of those
things is very is very well defined we
know you know given that it's the entity
City Chicago et cetera et cetera et
cetera you know Illinois United States
you know we know the geolocation of that
we know its population we know all kinds
of things about it which we have you
know curated that data to be able to to
know that with some degree of certainty
so to speak and then
then we can compute things from this and
that's that's kind of the
um yeah that's that's that's the idea
but then something like GPT large
language models do they allow you to uh
make that conversion much more powerful
okay so that's an interesting thing
which we still don't know everything
about okay the um I mean this question
of going from natural language to
computational language yes in will from
alpha we've now you know wolfenov has
been out and about for what 13 and a
half years now and you know we've
achieved I don't know what it is 98 99
success on queries that get put into it
now obviously there's a sort of feedback
loop because the things that work are
things people go on putting into it so
that that um uh but you know we've got
to a very high success rate of the the
little fragments of natural language
that put people put in you know
questions math calculations chemistry
calculations whatever it is you know we
can we can we we do very well at that
turning those things into to
computational language now I from the
very beginning of Orphan Alpha I thought
about for example uh writing code with
natural language
um in fact I had a I was just looking at
this recently I had a post that I wrote
in 2010 2011 called something like
programming with natural language is
actually going to work okay and so you
know we had done a bunch of experiments
using methods that were a little bit
some of them a little bit machine
learning like but certainly not the same
you know the same kind of idea of vast
training data and so on that is the
story of large language models actually
I know that that post a piece of utter
trivia but that that post um uh Steve
Jobs forwarded that post around to all
kinds of people at Apple you know that
was because he never really liked
programming languages so he was very
happy to see the idea that that that
that you could get rid of this kind of
layer of kind of engineering like
structure he would have liked you know I
think what's happening now because it
really is the case that you can you know
this idea that you have to kind of learn
how the computer works to use a
programming language is something that
is I think a a thing that you know just
like you had to learn the details of the
op codes to know how Assembly Language
worked and so on it's kind of a thing
that's that's that's a limited time
Horizon but but kind of the the you know
so this idea
of how elaborate can you make kind of
the prompt how elaborate can you make
the natural language and Abstract from
it computational language it's a very
interesting question and you know what
chat gbt you know gbt4 and so on can do
is pretty good
um it isn't it's very interesting
process I'm still trying to understand
this workflow we've been working out a
lot of tooling around this workflow the
natural language to computational
language right and the process
especially if it's conversation like
dialogue it's like multiple queries kind
of thing yeah right there's so many
things that are really interesting that
that work and so on so first thing is
can you just walk up to the computer and
expect to sort of specify a computation
what one realizes is humans have to have
some idea of kind of this way of
thinking about things computationally
without that you're kind of out of luck
because you just have no idea what
you're going to walk up to a computer I
remember when I should tell a silly
story about myself the very first
computer I saw which is when I was 10
years old it was a big Mainframe
computer and so on and I didn't really
understand what computers did and it's
like somebody's showing me this computer
and it's like uh you know can the
computer work out the weight of a
dinosaur it's like that isn't a sensible
thing to ask that's kind of you know you
have to give it that's not what
computers do I mean in Wolfram Alpha for
example you could say what's the typical
weight of a Stegosaurus and we'll give
you some answer but that's a very
different kind of thing from what one
thinks of computers as doing and so the
the kind of the the question of uh you
know first thing is people have to have
an idea of what what computation is
about
um you know I think it's a very you know
for Education that is the key thing it's
kind of this this uh this notion not
computer science not so the details of
programming but just this idea of how do
you think about the world
computationally computation thinking
about the world computationally is kind
of this formal way of thinking about the
world we've had other ones like logic
was a formal way you know as a way of
sort of abstracting and formalizing some
aspects of the world mathematics is
another one computation is this very
broad way of sort of formalizing the way
we think about the world and the thing
that's that's cool about computation is
if we can successfully formalize things
in terms of computation computers can
help us figure out what the consequences
are it's not like you formalized it with
math well that's nice but now you have
to if you're you know not using a
computer to do the math you have to go
work out a bunch of stuff yourself so I
think but that this idea let's see I
mean that you know we're trying to take
kind of the we're talking about sort of
natural language and its relationship to
computational language the uh the thing
the sort of the typical workflow I think
is first human has to have some kind of
idea of what they're trying to do that
if it's something that they want to sort
of build a tower of of capabilities on
something that they want to sort of
formalize and make computational
so then human can type something in to
you know some llm system and uh uh sort
of say vaguely what they want in sort of
computational terms then it does pretty
well at synthesizing wealth language
code and it'll probably do better in the
future because we've got a huge number
of examples of of natural language input
together with the wolf and language
translation of that so it's kind of a a
um uh you know that that's a thing where
you can kind of extrapolating from all
those examples uh makes it easier to do
that that toss is the prompter task
could also kind of debugging the Wolfram
language code
or is your hope to not do that debugging
no no no I mean so so there are many
steps here okay so first the first thing
is you type natural language it
generates woven language give examples
by the way you have an example that is
the the dinosaur example do you have an
example that jumps to mind that we
should be thinking about some dumb
example it's like take my heart rate
data and uh you know figure out whether
I uh you know make a moving average
every seven days or something and work
out what the um and make a plot of the
result okay so that's a thing which is
you know about two-thirds of a line of
language code I mean it's you know list
plot of moving average of some data bin
or something of the of the data and then
you'll get the result
um and you know the vague thing that I
was just saying in natural language
could would almost certainly correctly
turn into that very simple piece of
language code so you start mumbling
about heart rate
yeah and it kind of uh you know you
arrive at the moving average kind of
idea right you say average over seven
days maybe it'll figure out that that's
a moving you know that can be
encapsulated as this moving average idea
I'm not sure but then the typical
workflow but I'm seeing is you generate
this piece of language code it's pretty
small usually
um it's uh and if it isn't small it
probably isn't right but um you know if
it's it's pretty small and you know
wolfen language is one of the ideas of
Orphan languages it's a language that
humans can read it's not a language
which you know programming languages
tend to be this one-way story of humans
write them and computers execute from
them both from language is intended to
be something which is sort of like math
notation something where you know humans
write it and humans are supposed to read
it as well and so kind of the workflow
that's emerging is kind of this this
human mumbles some things you know large
language model produces a fragment of
awesome language code then you look at
that you say yeah that looks well
typically you just run it first you see
does it produce the right thing you look
at what it produces you might say that's
obviously crazy you look at the code you
see I see why it's crazy you fix it if
you really care about the result you
really want to make sure it's right you
better look at that code and understand
it because that's the way you have this
sort of checkpoint of did it really do
what I expected it to do now you go
beyond that I mean it's it's it's you
know what we find is for example let's
say the code does the wrong thing then
you can often say to the large language
model can you adjust this to do this
and it's pretty good at doing that
interesting so you're using the output
of the code
to give you hints
about the
the the function of the code so you're
debugging yeah based on the output of
the code itself right the plug-in that
we have the the you know for chat GPT it
does that routinely you know it will
send the thing in it will get a result
it will discover the llm will discover
itself that the result is not plausible
and it will go back and say oh I'm sorry
it's very polite and it you know it goes
back and says I'll rewrite that piece of
code and then it will try it again and
get the result the other thing that's
pretty interesting is when you're just
running so one of the new Concepts that
we have we invented this whole idea of
notebooks back 36 years ago now and so
now there's the question of sort of how
do you combine this idea of notebooks
where you have you know text and code
and output how do you combine that with
the notion of of chat and so on and
there's some really interesting things
there like for example a very typical
thing now is we have these these
notebooks where as soon as the if if the
thing produces errors if the you know
run this code and it produces messages
and so on the the llm automatically not
only looks at those messages it can also
see all kinds of internal information
about stack traces and things like this
and it can then it does a remarkably
good job of guessing what's wrong and
telling you so in other words it's it's
looking at things sort of interesting
it's kind of a typical sort of ai-ish
thing that it's able to have more
sensory data than we humans are able to
have because they're able to look at a
bunch of stuff that we humans would kind
of glaze over looking at and it's able
to then come up with oh this is the
explanation of what's happening and and
what is the data the stack trace the the
code you've written previously the
natural language you've written yeah
it's also what's happening is one of the
things that's uh is is for example when
there's these messages there's
documentation about these messages
there's examples of where the messages
have occurred otherwise nice all these
kinds of things the other thing that's
really amusing with this is when it
makes a mistake one of the things that's
in our prompt when the code doesn't work
is read the documentation
and we have a you know another piece of
the plugin that lets it read
documentation and that again is very
very useful because it it will you know
it will figure out sometimes it'll get
it'll make up the name of some option
for some function that doesn't really
exist read the documentation it'll have
you know some wrong structure for the
function and so on it's um that's a
powerful thing I mean the thing that you
know I've realized is we built this
language over the course of all these
years to be nice and coherent and
consistent and so on so it's easy for
humans to understand turns out there was
a side effect that I didn't anticipate
which is it makes it easier for AIS to
understand so it's almost like another
natural language but yeah so so wordful
language is a kind of foreign language
yes yes you have a lineup English French
Japanese Wolfram language and then uh I
don't know Spanish and then the system
is not going to notice well yes I mean
maybe you know that's an interesting
question because it really depends on
what I see as being a a important piece
of fundamental science that basically
just jumped out at us with Chachi BT
um because I think you know the real
question is why does chat GPD work how
is it possible to encapsulate you know
to successfully reproduce all these
kinds of things in natural language
um you know with a you know a
comparatively small he says you know a
couple hundred billion you know weights
of neural net and so on and I think that
uh you know that that relates to kind of
a fundamental fact about language which
uh you know the the main the main thing
is that I think there's a structure to
language that we haven't kind of really
explored very well as kind of the
semantic grammar I'm talking about about
um about language I mean we kind of know
that when we when we set up human
language we know that it has certain
regularities we know that it has a
certain grammatical structure you know
noun followed by verb followed by noun
adjectives etc etc et cetera that's its
kind of grammatical structure but I
think the thing that chat gbt is showing
us is that as an additional kind of
regularity to language which has to do
with the meaning of the language Beyond
just this pure you know part of speech
combination type of thing and I think
the uh the the kind of the the one
example of that that we've had in the
past is logic and you know I I think my
my sort of uh uh uh kind of picture of
how was logic invented how was logic
discovered uh it really was the thing
that was discovered in its original
conception it was discovered presumably
by Aristotle who kind of listened to a
bunch of people orators you know giving
speeches and this one made sense that
one doesn't make sense this one and you
know you see these patterns of you know
if the uh you know I don't know what you
know if the uh if the Persians do this
then this does that
Etc et cetera et cetera and what what
Aristotle realized is there's a
structure to those sentences there's a
structure to that rhetoric that doesn't
matter whether it's the Persians and the
Greeks or whether it's the cats and the
dogs it's just you know p and Q you can
abstract from this the the details of
these particular sentences you can lift
out this kind of formal structure and
that's what logic is that's a heck of a
discovery by the way logic you're making
me realize now
yeah it's not obvious the fact that
there is an abstraction from natural
language that has where you can fill in
any word you want yeah is a very
interesting Discovery now it took a long
time to mature I mean Aristotle had this
idea of syllogistic logic where there
were these particular patterns of how
you could argue things so to speak and
you know in the Middle Ages part of
Education was you memorize the
syllogisms I forget how many there were
but 15 of them or something and they all
had names they all had mnemonics like I
think Barbara and celerant were two of
the the mnemonics for the the syllogisms
and people would kind of this is a valid
argument because it follows The Barber
of syllogism so to speak and and it took
until 1830
um you know with uh George boole to kind
of get beyond that and kind of see that
there was a a level of abstraction that
was beyond the this particular template
of a sentence so to speak
um and that's you know what's
interesting there is in a sense you know
you know Chachi BT is operating at the
Aristotelian level it's essentially
dealing with templates of sentences by
the time you get to Bool and Boolean
algebra and this idea of you know you
can have arbitrary depth nested
collections of ants and ores and Knots
and you can resolve what they mean
um that's the kind of thing that's a
computation story that's you know you've
gone beyond the pure sort of templates
of natural language to something which
is an arbitrarily deep computation
but the thing that I think we realize
from from chat GPT is you know Aristotle
stopped too quickly and there was more
that you could have lifted out of
language as formal structures and I
think there's you know in a sense we've
captured some of that in in you know
some of what what is in language that
there's there's a there's a lot of kind
of little calculator little algebras of
of what you can say what language talks
about I mean whether it's I don't know
if you say uh
I go from place a to place B Place B to
place C then I know I've gone from place
a to place C
if a is a friend of B and B is a friend
of C it doesn't necessarily follow that
a is a friend of C these are things that
are uh you know that there are if if you
go from from place a to place B plus b
to place C it doesn't matter how you
went like logic it doesn't matter
whether you flew there walked there swam
there whatever you still this
transitivity of of where you go is still
valid and there are there are many kinds
of kind of features I think of the way
the world Works uh that are captured in
these aspects of of language so to speak
and I think what what chat gbt
effectively has found just like it
discovered logic you know people are
really surprised it can do these these
logical inferences it discovered Logic
the same way Aristotle discovered logic
by looking at a lot of sentences
effectively and noticing the patterns in
those sentences but it feels like it's
discovering something much more
complicated than logic so this kind of
semantic grammar I think he wrote about
this um
maybe you can call it the laws of
language I believe you call or which I
like the laws of thought yes that was
the title that George boole had for his
for his Boolean algebra back in 1830 but
yes as of thought yes that was what he
said
all right so he thought he thought he
nailed it with Boolean algebra yeah
there's more to it yeah it's a good
question how much more
is there to it and it seems like one of
the reasons as you uh imply that the
reason gbt Works chat GPT works is that
uh
there's a finite num number of things to
it yeah I mean it's discovering the laws
in some sense gbt is discovering this
laws of semantic grammar that underlies
language yes and what's sort of
interesting is in the computational
universe there's a lot of other kinds of
computation that you could do they're
just not ones that we humans have cared
about and and operate with and that's
probably because our brains are built in
a certain way and you know the neural
Nets of our brains are not that
different in some sense from the neural
Nets of of uh of a large language model
and that's kind of and so when we think
about and you know maybe we can talk
about this some more but when we think
about sort of what will AIS ultimately
do
the answer is insofar as AIS are just
doing computation they can run off and
do all these kinds of crazy computations
but the ones that we sort of have have
decided we care about are there is this
kind of very limited set
that's where the
uh reinforcement learning with human
feedback seems to come in the more the
AI say the stuff that kind of interests
us the more we're impressed by it
so you can do a lot of interesting
intelligent things but we're only
interested in the AI systems
when they communicate human in a
human-like way you ask about human-like
topics yes well it's it's like
technology I mean in a sense the
physical world provides all kinds of
things you know the all kinds of
processes going on in physics only a
limited set of those are ones that we
capture and use for technology because
they're only a limited set but we say
you know this is a thing that we can
sort of apply to the human purposes we
currently care about I mean you might
have said okay you pick up a piece of of
rock you say okay there's a nice
silicate it contains all kinds of
silicon I don't care then you realize oh
we could actually turn this into a you
know semiconductor wafer and make it
microprocessor out of it and then we
care a lot about it yes um and it's it's
you know it's this thing about what do
we you know in the evolution of our
civilization what things do we identify
as being things we care about I mean
it's like you know when when there was a
little announcement recently of the
possibility of a high temperature
superconductor that involved you know
the element lutetium which you know
generally nobody has cared about and you
know it's kind of um but suddenly if
there's this application that relates to
kind of human purposes we start to care
a lot so given your thinking that GPT
may have discovered inklings of laws of
thought do you think such laws exist can
we Linger on that what's your intuition
here oh definitely I mean the fact is
look the the logic is but the first step
there are many other kinds of calculi
about things that uh we consider you
know the about sort of things that
happen in the world or things that are
meaningful well how do you know logic is
not the last step you know what I mean
so because we can plainly see that that
thing I mean if you say here's a
sentence that is syntactically correct
okay you look at it and you're like you
know the happy electron you know know
eight
I don't know what some something that it
just it you look at and it's like this
is meaningless it's just a bunch of
words it's syntactically correct the
nouns and the verbs are in the right
place but it just doesn't mean anything
um and so there clearly is some rule
that there are rules that determine when
a sentence is has the potential to be
meaningful that go beyond the pure parts
of speech syntax and so the question is
what are those rules and are there
fairly finite set of those rules my
guess is that there's a fairly finite
set of those rules and they you know
once you have those rules you have a
kind of a construction kit just like
this the rules of syntactic grammar give
you a construction kit for making
syntactically correct sentences so you
can also have a construction kit for
making semantically correct sentences
those sentences may not be realized in
the world I mean I think you know the
elephant flew to the moon yeah a a
syntactic a semantically you know we
know we have an idea if I say that to
you you kind of know what that means but
the fact is it hasn't been realized in
the world so to speak so semantically
correct perhaps there's things that can
be imagined with the human mind no uh
things that are
consistent with both our imagination and
our understanding of physical reality I
don't know yeah good question I mean
it's a good question it's a good
question I mean I think it is it is
given the way we have constructed
language it is things which which fit
with the things we're describing in
language it's a bit circular in the end
because you know you can and and the and
the the sort of boundaries of what is
physically realizable okay let's take
the example of motion okay motion is a
complicated concept it might seem like
it's a concept that should have been
figured out by the Greeks you know long
ago but it's actually really pretty
complicated concept because what is
motion motion is you can go from place a
to place B and it's still you when you
get to the other end right you you take
an object you move it and it's still the
same object but it's in a different
place now even in ordinary physics that
doesn't always work that way if you're
near a space-time singularity in a black
hole for example and you take your
teapot or something you don't have much
of a teapot by the time it's near the
space-time Singularity it's been
completely you know deformed beyond
recognition but so that's a case where
pure emotion doesn't really work you
can't have a thing stay the same but so
this idea of motion is is something that
sort of is a slightly complicated idea
but once you have the idea of motion you
can start once you have the idea that
you're going to describe things as being
the same thing but in a different place
that sort of abstracted idea then has
you know that has all sorts of
consequences like this transitivity of
motion go from A to B B to C you've gone
from a to c
um and that's so that level of
description you can have what are sort
of uh inevitable consequences they're
inevitable features of the way you've
sort of set things up and that's I think
what this sort of semantic grammar is
capturing is things things like that and
I you know I think that it's a question
of what does the word mean when you say
I go from I move from here to there well
it's complicated to say what that means
this is this whole issue of you know is
pure motion possible Etc et cetera et
cetera but once you have kind of got an
idea of what that means then there are
inevitable consequences of that idea
but the very idea of meaning it seems
like there's some words that become
um
it's like there's a latent ambiguity to
them I mean it's the word like
emotionally loaded words like hate and
love
right it's like what what are they what
do they mean exactly like what
um so especially when you have
relationships between complicated
objects we seem to take this kind of
shortcut descriptive shortcut of to
describe like right object a hates
object B what's that really mean right
well words are defined by kind of our
social use of them I mean it's not you
know a word
in computational language for example
when we say we have a a construct there
we expect that that construct is a
building block from which we can
construct an arbitrarily tall tower so
we have to have a very solid building
block and you know we have to it turns
into a piece of code it has
documentation it's you know it's a whole
it's a whole thing but the word hate you
know the documentation for that word
well there isn't a standard
documentation for that word so to speak
it's a complicated thing defined by kind
of how we use it when you know if it
wasn't for the fact that we were using
language I mean so so what is language
at some level language is a way of
packaging thoughts so that we can
communicate them to another mind can
these complicated words
be converted into something that a
computation engine can use right so so I
think the answer to that is that that
what one can do in computational
language is Define make a def make a
specific definition and if you have a
complicated word like let's say the word
eat okay you'd think that's a simple
word it's you know animals eat things
whatever else but you know you do
programming you say this function eats
arguments which is sort of poetically
similar to the animal eating things but
if you start to say well what are the
implications of you know uh the function
eating something you know does it can
can the function be poisoned well maybe
it can actually but um uh you know if
there's a tight mismatch or something in
some language but but you know in what
how far does that analogy go and it's
it's just an analogy whereas if you use
the word eat
in a computational language level you
would Define there isn't a thing which
you anchor to the kind of natural
language concept eat but it is now some
precise definition of that that then you
can compute things from but don't you
think the analogy is also precise
software eats the world don't you think
there's a
there's something Concrete in terms of
meaning about analogies sure but the
thing that sort of is the first Target
for computational language is to take
sort of the ordinary meaning of things
and try and make it precise make it
sufficiently precise you can build these
towers of computation on top of it so
it's kind of like if you start with a
piece of poetry and you say I'm going to
Define my program with this piece of
poetry it's kind of like that's that's a
difficult thing it's better to say I'm
going to just have this boring piece of
prose and it's using words in the
ordinary way and that time communicating
with my computer and that's how I'm
going to build the solid building block
from which I can construct this whole
kind of computational Tower so there's
some sense where if you take a poem and
reduce it to something computable you're
going to have very few things left so
maybe there's a bunch of human
interaction that's just poetic
aimless nonsense
well that's just like recreational like
hamster in a wheel it's not actually
producing anything well I I I think that
that's a complicated thing because in a
sense human linguistic communication is
there's one mind it's producing language
that language is having an effect on
another mind yeah and the question of
there's sort of a a type of effect that
is well defined let's say where where
for example it's very independent of the
two minds that the it doesn't you know
that there there's communication where
it can matter a lot sort of what the
experience of of um uh of one mind is
versus another one and so on
yeah but uh
what is the purpose of natural language
communication
well I think I think versus so
computation computational language
somehow feels more amenable to the
definition of purpose it's like yeah
you're given two
clean representations of a concept and
you can build a tower based on that is
is natural language the same thing but
more fuzzy what well I think the the
story of natural language right in the
the that's the great invention of our
species we don't know whether exists in
other species but we know it exists in
our species it's the thing that allows
you to sort of communicate abstractly
from like one generation of the species
to another you can you know there is an
abstract version of knowledge that can
be passed down it doesn't have to be you
know genetics it doesn't have to be you
know you don't have to Apprentice the
next species you know the next
generation of birds to the previous one
to show them how something works yeah
there is this abstracted version of
knowledge that can be kind of passed
down now that you know it relies on it
still tends to rely because language is
fuzzy it does tend to rely on the fact
that you know if we look at the you know
some ancient language that where we
don't have a chain of translations from
it until what we have today we may not
understand that ancient language
um and we may not understand you know
its Concepts may be different from the
ones that we have today we still have to
have something of a chain but it is
something where we can realistically
expect to communicate abstract ideas and
that's you know that's one of the big
big roles of a language I think you know
in in um
uh it's you know that that's been this
this ability to sort of concretify
abstract things is what what language
was provided do you see natural language
and thought as the same the stuff that's
gone inside your mind
well
that's been a long debate in philosophy
it seems to be become more important now
when we think about
how intelligent GPT is
whatever that means whatever that means
but it seems like the stuff that's going
on in the human mind seems something
like intelligence is a language well we
call it intelligence yeah we call it
well yes and so you start to think of
okay what's the relationship between
thought
the language of thought the laws of
thought the laws of the words like
reasoning
and the laws of language and how that
has to do with computation which seems
like a more rigorous precise ways of
reasoning right which are Beyond human I
mean much of what computers do human
humans do not do I mean you might say
humans are a subset yeah presumably yes
hopefully yes the the yes right you know
you might say who needs computation when
we have large language models large
language models can just you know
eventually you'll have a big enough
neuron that it can do anything but
they're really doing the kinds of things
that humans quickly do and they're
plenty of sort of formal things that
humans never quickly do for example I
don't know I you know you can some
people can do mental arithmetic they can
do a certain amount of math in their in
their minds I don't think many people
can run a program in their minds of any
sophistication it's just not something
people do it's not something people have
even thought of doing because just it's
kind of a it's kind of not you know you
can easily run it on a computer when
another portrayed program yeah aren't we
running specialized programs yeah yeah
but if I say to you run this there's a
turing machine yeah you know tell me
what it does after 50 steps and you're
like trying to think about that in your
mind that's really hard to do it's not
what people do I mean well in some sense
people program they build a computer
they program it just to answer your
question about what the system does
after 50 steps I mean humans build
computers yes yes yeah that's right but
they've created something which is then
you know then when they run it it's
doing something different than what's
happening in their minds I mean they've
outsourced that that piece of
computation from something that is
internally happening in their minds to
something that is now a tool that's
external to their minds so whether we're
humans to you didn't invent computers
they discovered them
they discovered computation which they
invented the technology of computers
this the computer is just a
kind of way to plug into this whole this
stream of computation which probably
other other ways for sure I mean the the
you know the particular ways that we
make computers out of semiconductors and
electronics and so on that's the
particular technology stack we built I
mean the story of a lot of what people
try to do with Quantum Computing is
finding different sort of underlying
physical you know infrastructure for
doing computation you know biology does
lots of computation it does it using an
infrastructure that's different from
semiconductors and electronics it's a
you know it's a molecular scale uh sort
of computational process that hopefully
we'll understand more about I have some
ideas about understanding more about
that but uh you know that's that's
another ins you know it's another
representation of computation things
that happen in the physical Universe at
the level of you know these evolving
hypographs and so on that's another sort
of implementation layer for this
abstract idea of computation so if GPT
or large language models starting to
form
starting to develop or implicitly
understand the laws of language and
thought do you think they can be made
explicit yes how he had a bunch of
effort I mean doing Natural Science I
mean what is happening in Natural
Science you have the world that's doing
all these complicated things and then
you discover you know Newton's laws for
example this is how emotion works this
is the way that this particular sort of
idealization of the world this is how we
describe it in a simple computationally
reducible way and I think it's the same
thing here it's there are sort of
computationally reducible aspects of
what's Happening that you can get a kind
of narrative theory for just as we've
got narrative theories in physics and so
on
thank you
do you think it will be
depressing or exciting
when all the laws of thought are made
explicit human thought made explicit I
think that once you understand
computational reducibility it is uh it's
neither of those things because the fact
is people say for example that people
will say oh but you know I have free
will I I kind of um you know I operate
in a way that is uh uh um you know you
you uh the the the they have the idea
that they're doing something that is
sort of of internal to them that they're
figuring out what's what's happening but
in fact we think there are laws of
physics that ultimately determine you
know every uh every nerve you know every
electrical impulse and a nerve and
things like this so you might say isn't
it depressing that we are ultimately
just determined by the rules of physics
so to speak
um it's the same thing it's at a higher
level it's like it's it's it's a shorter
distance to get from kind of semantic
grammar to the way that we might
construct a piece of text than it is to
get from Individual nerve firings to how
we construct a piece of text but it's
not fundamentally different and by the
way as soon as we have this kind of
level of you know this other level of
description it's kind of it helps us to
go even further so we'll end up being
able to produce more and more
complicated Kinds of Kinds of things
that just like when we you know if we
didn't have a computer and we knew
certain rules we could write them down
and go a certain distance but once we
have a computer we can go vastly further
and this is the same kind of thing you
wrote a blog post titled what is Chad
GPT doing and where does it work we've
been talking about this but can we just
step back and Linger on this question
what what's it what's Chad GPT doing
what are these
um
a bunch of billion parameters trained on
a large number of words like what why
does it seem to work again is it is it
because to the point you made that
there's laws of language that can be
discovered by such a process is there
something well let's let's talk about
sort of the low level of what chat GPT
is doing I mean ultimately you give it a
prompt it's trying to work out you know
what should the next word be right which
is wild isn't that isn't that surprising
to you that this kind of low level dumb
training procedure can create something
syntactically correct first and then
semantically correct you know the thing
that has been sort of a story of my life
is realizing that simple rules can do
much more complicated things than you
imagine that something that starts
simple and start simple to describe can
grow a thing that is you know vastly
more complicated than you can imagine
and honestly it's taken me I don't know
I've sort of been thinking about this
now 40 years or so and it always
surprises me I mean even for example in
our physics project sort of thinking
about the whole universe growing from
these simple rules I still resist
because I keep on thinking you know how
can something really complicated arise
from something that simple it just seems
you know it seems wrong but yet you know
the majority of my life I've kind of
known from from things I've studied that
this is the way things work so yes I it
is wild that it's possible to write a
word at a time and produce a coherent
essay for example but it's worth
understanding kind of how that's working
I mean it's kind of like if if it was
going to say you know the cat sat on the
what's the next word okay so how does it
figure out the next word well it's seen
a trillion words written on the internet
and it's seen the cat sat on the floor
the cat sat on the sofa the cat sat on
the whatever so it's minimal thing to do
is just say let's look at what we saw on
the internet we saw you know 10 000
examples of the cat sat on the what was
the most probable next word let's just
pick that out and say that's the next
word and that's that's kind of what it
is at some level is trying to do now the
problem is there isn't enough text on
the internet to uh for if you have a
reasonable length of prompt to that that
PR that specific prompt will never have
occurred on the internet and as you as
you kind of go further there just won't
be a place where you could have trained
you know where you could just worked out
probabilities from what was already
there
um you know like if you say two plus two
there'll be a zillion examples of two
plus two equaling four and a very small
number of examples of two plus two
equals five and so on and you can pretty
much know what's going to happen so then
the question is well if you can't just
work out from examples what's going to
happen just no probabilistic for you for
examples what's going to happen you have
have to have a model and there's kind of
an idea this idea of making models of
things is an idea that really I don't
know I think Galileo probably was one of
the first people who sort of worked this
out and it's kind of like like you know
I think I gave an example of that little
book I wrote about about Chachi BT where
it's kind of like you know Galileo was
dropping cannonballs off the off the
different floors of the of the Tower of
Pisa and it's like okay you drop a
cannonball off this floor you drop a
cannonball off this floor you miss floor
five or something for whatever reason
but you know the time it took the
Cannonball to fall to the ground from
floors one two three four six seven
eight for example then the question is
can you work out can you can you make a
model which figures out how long did it
take the ball how long would it take the
ball to fall to the ground from the
floor you didn't explicitly measure and
the thing Galileo realized is that you
can use math you can use mathematical
formulas to make a model for how long it
will take the ball to fall so now the
question is well okay you want to make a
model for for example something much
more elaborate like you've got this
arrangement of pixels and is this
arrangement of pixels an A or a B does
it correspond to something we'd
recognize as an A or B and you can make
a similar kind you know each pixel is
like a parameter in some equation and
you could write down this giant equation
where the answer is either you know a or
you know one or two A or B
um and the question is then what kind of
a model successfully reproduces the way
that we humans would would conclude that
this is an A and this is a b you know if
there's a complicated extra tail on the
top of the a would we then conclude
something different what is the type of
model that Maps well into the way that
we humans make distinctions about things
and the big kind of meta Discovery is
neural Nets are such a model it's not
obvious they would be such a model it
could be that human distinctions are not
captured you know we could try such
around for a type of model that could be
a mathematical model it could be some
model based on something else that
captures kind of typical human
distinctions about things it turns out
this model that actually is very much
the way that we think the architecture
of brains works that perhaps not
surprisingly that model actually
corresponds to the way we make these
distinctions and so you know the the
core next point is that the the kind of
model that's neural net model makes sort
of distinctions and generalizes things
in sort of the same way that we humans
do it and that's why when you say you
know the cat set on the green blank even
though it never didn't see many examples
of the cat said on the green whatever it
can make a or the aardvark sat on the
green whatever I'm sure that particular
sentence does not occur on the internet
and so it has to make a model that
concludes what you know it has to kind
of generalize from what it's from the
actual example that it's seen and so so
you know that that's the fact is that
neural Nets generalize in the same kind
of way that we humans do if if we were
you know the aliens might look at our
neural net generalizations and say
that's crazy you know that thing when
you put that extra little dot on the a
that isn't an a anymore that's you know
that messed the whole thing up but for
us humans we make distinctions which
seem to correspond to the kinds of
distinctions that neural Nets make so
then you know the the thing that is just
amazing to me about chat gbt is how
similar the structure it has is to the
very original way people imagine neural
Nets might work back in 1943 and you
know there's a lot of detailed
engineering you know great cleverness
but it's really the same idea and in
fact even the sort of elaborations of
that idea where people said let's put in
some actual particular structure to try
and make the neural net more elaborate
to be very clever about it most of that
didn't matter I mean there's some things
that seem to you know when you when you
train this neural net you know the one
thing this kind of Transformer
architecture this attention idea that
really has to do with does every one of
these neurons connect to every other
neuron or is it somehow causally
localized so to speak does it like we're
making a sequence of words and the words
depend on previous words rather than
just everything can depend on everything
and that seems to be important in just
organizing things so that you don't have
a sort of a giant mess but the thing you
know the thing worth understanding about
what is chat gpg in the end I mean what
is a neural that's in the end a neural
net in the end is each neuron has a it
it's taking inputs from a bunch of other
neurons it's it's eventually it's going
to have uh it's going to have a a
numerical value it's going to compute
some number and it's it's saying I'm
going to look at the the neurons above
me it's kind of a series of layers it's
going to look at the neurons above me
and it's going to say what are the
values of all those neurons then it's
going to add those up and multiply them
by these weights and then it's going to
apply some function that says if it's
bigger than zero or something then make
it one or an otherwise make it zero or
some slightly more complicated function
you know very well how this works but
it's a giant equation with a lot of
variables you mentioned figuring out
where the ball Falls when you don't have
data on the fourth floor
um this the equation here is not as
simple as the equation but the 175
billion terms and it's quite surprising
that in some sense a simple procedure of
uh training such an equation can lead to
well I think that good representation of
natural language right the the real
issue is you know this architecture of a
neural net where where what's happening
is you know you've you've you've turned
so neural Nets always just deal with
numbers and so you know you've turned
the sentence that you started with into
a bunch of numbers like let's say by
mapping you know each word of the 50 000
words in English you just map each word
or each part of a word into some number
they feed all those numbers in
and then the thing is going to and then
those numbers just go into the values of
these neurons and then what happens is
it's just Rippling down going layer to
layer until it gets to the end I think
chat gbg has about 400 layers and you're
just you know it just goes once through
it just every every new word it's going
to compute just says here are the here
are the numbers from the words before
let's compute the what is it compute it
computes the probabilities that it
estimates for each of the possible 50
000 words that could come next and then
it decides sometimes it will use the
most probable word sometimes it will use
not the most probable word it's an
interesting fact that there's this
so-called temperature parameter which
you know at temperature zero it's always
using the most probable word that it can
that it estimated was the the most
probable thing to come next you know if
you increase the temperature it'll be
more and more kind of random in its
selection of words it'll go down to
lower and lower probability words thing
I was just playing with actually
recently was the transition that happens
as you increase the temperature the
thing goes Bonkers at a particular you
know sometimes at a particular
temperature I think maybe about 1.2 is
the thing I was noticing from yesterday
actually
um that you know usually it's giving
reasonable answers and then uh at that
temperature with some probability it
just starts spouting nonsense
um and you know nobody knows why this
happens I mean it's it's uh uh and by
the way I mean the thing to understand
is it's putting down one word at a time
but the outer loop of the fact that it
says okay I put down a word now let's
take the whole thing I wrote so far
let's feed that back in let's put down
another word that outer loop which seems
almost trivial is really important to
the operation of the thing and and for
example one of the things that is kind
of funky is it'll give an answer and you
say to it is that answer correct and
it'll say no
and why is that happening right right
why couldn't it do that well the answer
is because it is going one word at a
time sort of forwards and it didn't you
know it it came along with some sort of
chain of of thought in a sense and it
came up with completely the wrong answer
but as soon as you feed it the whole
thing that it came up with it
immediately knows that that isn't right
it immediately can recognize that was a
you know a bad syllogism or something
and uh can see what happened even though
as it was being led down this Garden
Path so to speak it didn't it came to
the wrong place but it's fascinating
that this kind of procedure converges to
something that forms a pretty good
compressed representation of language on
the internet yeah that's quite right
right no I'm not sure what to make of it
well look I think you know there are
many things we don't understand okay so
for example you know 175 billion weights
it's maybe about a trillion bytes of
information which is very comparable to
the training set that was used
um and uh you know why that why kind of
it sort of stands to some kind of reason
that the number of Weights in the neural
net I don't know where I can't really
argue that I can't really give you a
good uh you know in a sense the very
fact that you know the insofar as there
are definite rules of what's going on
you might expect that eventually we'll
have a much smaller neural net that will
successfully capture what's happening I
I don't think the best way to do it is
probably a neural net I think a neuron
that is what you do when you don't know
any other way to structure the thing and
it's a very good thing to do if you
don't know any other way to structure
the thing and for the last 2000 years we
haven't known any other way to structure
it so this is a pretty good way to start
but that doesn't mean you can't find
sort of in a sense more symbolic rules
for what's going on that you know much
of which will then be you can kind of
get rid of much of the structure of the
neural Nets and replace it by things
which are sort of pure steps of
computation so to speak sort of with
neural net stuff around the edges and
that becomes just a you know just a much
simpler way to do it so then you're on
that you hope will reveal
to us uh good symbolic rules that make
the needs and you're on that less and
less and less right and and there will
still be some stuff that's kind of fuzzy
just like you know that they're things
that it's like this question of what can
we formalize what can we turn into
computational language what is just sort
of oh it happens that way just because
brains are set up that way
what do you think are the limitations of
uh large language models just to make it
explicit well I mean I think that deep
computation is not what large language
models do I mean that's just it's a
different kind of thing you know the
outer loop of a large language model if
if you're trying to do many steps in a
computation the only way you get to do
that right now is by spooling out you
know all that the whole Chain of Thought
as a bunch of words basically and you
know you can make a turing machine out
of that if you want to I just was make
doing that construction you know in
principle you can make an arbitrary
computation by just spooling out the
words but it's an it's a bizarre and
inefficient way to do it
um but it's something where uh the you
know I I think that's you know sort of
the the Deep computation it's it's
really what a human's can do quickly
large language models will probably be
able to do well anything that you can do
kind of off the top of your head type
thing is is really you know is good for
large language models and the things you
do off the top of your head you may not
get them always right but you know
you'll it it's it's thinking it through
the same way we do but I wonder if
there's an automated way to do something
that humans do
well much faster to where it like Loops
so generate arbitrary large code bases
of Wolfram language for example
well the question is what does what do
you want the code base to do
um Escape control and take over the
world okay so you know the thing is when
people say you know we want to build
this giant thing right a giant piece of
computational language in a sense it's
sort of a failure of computational
language if the thing you have to build
in other words if we have a description
if you have a small description
that's the thing that you represent in
computational language and then the
computer can compute from that yes so in
a sense in you know when as soon as
you're giving a description that you
know if you have to somehow make that
description something you know definite
something formal and once and and to say
to say okay I'm going to give this piece
of natural language and then it's going
to splurt out this giant formal
structure that in a sense that doesn't
that doesn't really make sense because
acceptanceofar as that piece of natural
language kind of plugs into what we
socially know so to speak it plugs into
kind of our Corpus of knowledge then you
know that's the way we're capturing a
piece of that Corpus of knowledge but
hopefully we will have done that in
computational language how do you make
it do something that's big well you know
you have to have a way to describe what
you want okay I can make it more
explicit if you want how about I just
pop into my head
um iterate
through all the members of Congress
and figure out how to convince them that
they have to
let
me
this meaning the system become president
pass all the laws that allows AI systems
to to control and be the president I
don't know so that's a very explicit
like figure out the individual life
story of each Congressman that each
senator anybody I don't know
what's required to really kind of pass
legislation and figure out how to
control them and manipulate them get all
the information what would be the
biggest fear of this congressman and uh
in such a way that you can take action
on it in the digital space so maybe
threaten the destruction reputation or
something like this right if I can
describe what I want yeah you know to
what extent can a large language model
automate that with the help uh with the
help of the concretization of something
like Wolfram language
that makes it more
um yeah ground it can go rather a long
way I'm also surprised how quickly I was
able to generate yeah yeah right an
attack
that that's the here you know I I swear
I swear I did not think about this
before and it's funny how quickly which
is a very concerning thing because that
that probably this idea will probably do
quite a bit of damage and there might be
a very large number of other such ideas
well I'll give you a much more benign
version of that idea okay you're gonna
make an AI tutoring system and you know
that is a that's a benign version of
what you're saying is
um I want this person to understand this
point yes you know you're essentially
doing machine learning where the where
the where the you know the the loss
function the the thing you're trying to
get to is get the human to understand
this point and and when you do a test on
the human that they yes they correctly
understand how this or that works and I
I am confident that uh you know sort of
the large language model type technology
combined with computational language is
going to be able to do pretty pretty
well at teaching us humans things and
it's going to be an interesting
phenomenon because you know sort of
individualized teaching is is a thing
that has been kind of a you know a goal
for a long time I think we're going to
get that and I think more you know that
it has many consequences for you know
like like just you know if you know me
as an if you the AI know me tell me I'm
about to do this thing what is the what
are the three things I need to know you
know given what I already know you know
what's the what let's say I'm I'm
looking at some paper or something right
it's it's like there's a version of this
summary of that paper that is optimized
for me so to speak and where it really
is and I think that's really going to
work it could understand the the major
gaps in your knowledge yes that if field
would actually give you uh
a deeper understanding of the topic here
right and that's a you know that's an
important thing because it really
changes actually I think you know when
when you think about education and so on
it really changes kind of what's worth
doing what's not worth doing and so on
it makes you know I know in my life I've
learned lots of different fields and you
know so I yeah I don't know every time I
always think this is the one that's
going to I'm not going to be able to
learn yeah but turns out sort of there
are sort of meta methods for learning
these things in the end
um and you know I think this this idea
that it becomes easier to you know it
becomes easier to be fed knowledge so to
speak and it becomes you know if you
need to know this particular thing you
can you know you can get taught it in an
efficient way is something I think is
sort of a an interesting feature and I
think it makes the um
you know things like the value of of big
towers of specialized knowledge become
less significant compared to the kind of
meta knowledge of sort of understanding
kind of the the big picture and being
able to connect things together I think
that you know there's been this huge
trend of let's be more and more
specialized because we have to you know
we we have to sort of Ascend these
towers of knowledge but by the time you
can get you know more automation of
being able to get to that place on the
tower without having to go through all
those steps I think it sort of changes
that picture interesting so your
intuition is that in terms of the the
the collective intelligence of the
species in the individual minds they
make up that Collective
there'll be more they will Trend towards
being generalists and being kind of
philosophers that's what I think I think
that's where the humans are going to be
useful I think that a lot of these kind
of
the drilling the the the mechanical
working out of things is much more
automatable it's much more ai ai
territory so to speak no more phds
well that's a it's interesting yes I
mean you know the the kind of the
specialization this kind of tower of
specialization which has been a feature
of you know we've accumulated lots of
knowledge in our in our species and and
you know in a sense every time we every
time we have an a kind of automation a
building of tools it becomes less
necessary to know that whole Tower and
it becomes something where you can just
use a tool to get to the top of that
Tower I I think that um uh you know the
thing that is ultimately you know when
we think about okay what do the AIS do
versus what do the humans do it's like
ai's you tell them you say go achieve
this particular objective okay they can
maybe figure out a way to achieve that
objective we say what objective would
you like to achieve
the AI has no intrinsic idea of that
it's not a defined thing that's a thing
which has to come from some other you
know some other entity and insofar as we
are in charge so to speak or whatever it
is and our kind of web of society and
history and so on is the thing that is
defining what objective we want to go to
that's you know that that's that's the
thing that we humans are necessarily
involved in so to push back a little bit
don't you think that GPT feature
versions of GPT
would be able to give a good answer to
what objective would you like to achieve
from on what basis I mean if they say
look here's the terrible thing that
could happen Okay that taking the
average of the internet and they're
saying you know from the average of the
internet what do people want to do well
that's the uh the Elon Musk outage of
the most entertaining outcome is the
most likely
okay
that could be um
that could be one objective
is maximize
global
entertainment the dark version of that
is drama the the good version of that is
fun
right so I mean this this question of
what uh you know if you say to the AI
um you know uh what does the species
want to achieve
yes okay there'll be an answer right
that'll be an answer it'll be what the
average of the internet says the species
wants to achieve well this this I think
you're using the word average very
Loosely there right so
I think you I think the answers will
become more and more interesting as
these language models are trained better
and better no but I mean in the end it's
a reflection back of what we've already
said
yes but it's uh there's a deeper wisdom
to the collective intelligence
presumably than each individual maybe
isn't that what we're trying to just
Society uh to have well I mean that's
that's a that's an important no that's
an interesting question I mean in you
know insofar as some of us you know work
on trying to innovate and figure out new
things and so on it is sometimes it's a
it's a complicated interplay between
sort of the individual doing the crazy
thing often some some spur so to speak
versus the collective that's trying to
do sort of the the the the high inertia
average thing and it's you know
sometimes the collective you know is is
bubbling up things that are interesting
and sometimes it's pulling down kind of
the attempt to make this kind of
innovative Direction but don't you think
the large language models would see
beyond that simplification it will say
maybe intellectual and career diversity
is really important so you need the
crazy people from the outlier on the
outskirts and so like the actual what's
the purpose of this whole thing is to
explore
through this kind of dynamics that we've
been using as a human civilization which
is most of us focused on one thing and
then there's the crazy people on the
outskirts doing the opposite of that one
thing and you kind of like pull the
whole society together there's the
mainstream science and then there's the
crazy science that's just been enough of
the history of human civilization and
maybe the AI system will be able to see
that and the more and more impressed we
are by
a language model telling us this the
more control will give it to it and the
more we'll be willing to let it run our
society and hence there's this kind of
loop where the society could be
manipulated to let the AI system run it
right well I mean look one of the things
that's sort of interesting is we might
say we always think we're making
progress but yet if you know in a sense
by by saying let's take what already
exists and use that as a model for what
should exist yeah then you know it's
interesting that for example you know
many religions have taken that point of
view there is a you know a sacred book
that got written at Timex and it defines
how people should act for all future
time and that's you know it's it's a
model that people have operated with and
in a sense you know this is a version of
that that kind of statement it's like
take the 2023 version of sort of how the
world has exposed itself
and use that to Define what the world
should do in the future but it's not
it's an imprecise definition right
because just like with religious text
and with GPT the human interpretation of
what GPT says
will be the um
uh will be the perturbation in the
system it'll be the noise it'd be full
of uncertainty it's not like GPT will
tell you exactly what to do
it'll tell you approx A Narrative of
what like uh uh you know it's like turn
the other cheek kind of narrative right
that's that's not a fully instructive
narrative well until until the AIS
control all the systems in the world
they will be able to very precisely tell
you what to do but they'll do what they
you know they'll they'll just do this or
that thing and and that and and not only
that they'll be Auto suggesting to each
person you know do this next do that
next so I think it's a it's a slightly
more prescriptive situation than one has
typically seen but you know I think this
this whole question of sort of what
what's left for the humans so to speak
to what extent do we uh you know this
idea that there is an existing kind of
Corpus of purpose for humans defined by
what's on the internet and so on that's
an important thing but then the question
of sort of as we explore what we can
think of as the computational universe
as we explore all these different
possibilities for what we could do all
these different inventions we could make
all these different things the question
is which ones do we choose to follow
those choices are the things that in a
sense if the humans want to still have
kind of human progress that's what we we
get to make those choices so to speak in
other words the the there's this idea if
you say let's take
the uh kind of what exists today and use
that as the determiner of all of what
there is in the future
the thing that is sort of the
opportunity for humans is there will be
many possibilities thrown up there are
many different things that could happen
or be done and the insofar as we want to
be in the loop the thing that makes
sense for us to be in the loop doing is
picking which of those possibilities we
want
but the degree to which there's a
feedback loop
of the idea that we're picking something
starts becoming questionable because
we're influenced by the various systems
absolutely if that becomes more and more
source of our education and wisdom and
knowledge
right the AIS take over I mean my you
know I thought for a long time that you
know it's the you know AR Auto
suggestion that's really the thing that
makes the AIS take over it's just then
the humans just follow you know yeah we
will no longer write emails to each
other we'll just send the auto suggested
email yeah yeah but the the thing where
humans are potentially in the loop is
when there's a choice and when there's a
choice which we could make based on our
kind of whole web of history and so on
yeah and and that's you know that's
insofar as it's all just you know
determined uh you know the humans don't
have a place and and by the way I mean
you know at some level uh you know it's
all kind of a complicated philosophical
issue because at some level the universe
is just doing what it does we are parts
of that universe that are necessarily
doing what we do so to speak yet we feel
we have sort of agency in what we're
doing and that's that's its own separate
kind of interesting issue and we also
kind of feel like we're the Final
Destination what the universe was meant
to create
uh but we very well could be and likely
are some kind of intermediate step
obviously yeah well we're we're most
certainly some intermediate stuff the
question is if there's some cooler more
complex more interesting uh things
that's going to be materialized the
computational universe is full of such
things but in our particular pocket
specifically if this is the best we're
going to do or not that's kind of a we
can make all kinds of interesting things
in the computational universe we when we
look at them we say yeah you know that's
that's a thing we don't it doesn't
really connect with our current uh our
current way of thinking about things
it's like in mathematics you know we've
got certain theorems they're about three
or four million that human
mathematicians have written down and
published and so on but they're an
infinite number of possible mathematical
theorems we just go out into the
universe of possible theorems and pick
another theorem and then people will say
well you know that's the you know they
look at it and they say I don't know
what this theorem means it's not
connected to the things that are part of
kind of the web of history that we're
dealing with you know I think one one
point to make about sort of
understanding Ai and its relationship to
us is as we have this kind of whole
infrastructure of AIS doing their thing
and doing their thing in a way that is
perhaps not readily understandable by us
humans you know you might say that's a
that's a very weird situation how can we
have built this thing that behaves in a
way that we can't understand that's full
of computational irreducibility et
cetera et cetera et cetera you know what
what is this what's it going to feel
like when the world is run by AIS whose
operations we can't understand and the
thing one realizes is actually we've
seen this before that's what happens
when we exist in the natural world the
natural world is full of things that
operate according to definite rules they
have all kinds of you know computational
reducibility we don't understand what
the natural world is doing occasionally
and you know when you say you know are
the AIS going to wipe us out for example
well it's kind of like is the
machination of the AIS going to lead to
this thing that eventually comes and
destroys the species well we can also
ask the same thing about the natural
world or the imagination of the natural
world going to eventually lead to this
thing that's going to you know make make
the earth explode or something like this
those are those are questions those are
and insofar as we think we understand
what's happening in the natural world
that's a result of Science and natural
science and so on one of the things we
can expect when there's this giant
infrastructure of the AIS is that's
where we have to kind of invent a new
kind of natural science that kind of is
the natural science that explains to us
how the AIS work it's kind of like we
can we can you know we have a I don't
know a horse or something and we're
trying to get it we're trying to you
know ride the horse and go from here to
there we don't really understand how the
horse Works inside but we can get
certain rules and certain you know
approaches that we take to persuade the
horse to go from here to there and and
and take us there and that's the same
type of thing we're kind of dealing with
with the sort of incomprehensible
computationally irreducible AIS but we
can identify these kinds of we can find
these kind of pockets of reducibility
that we can kind of uh you know I don't
know we're grabbing onto the main of the
horse or something to be able to to ride
it
um or we figure out you know if we if we
do this or that to to ride the horse
that that's a a successful way to get it
to do what what we're interested in
doing